PRESIDENT BIDEN'S BORDER CRISIS
HITTING A NEW LOW AS THE WHITE
HOUSE IS REPORTEDLY CONSIDERING
A PLAN TO SEND A SURGE OF
HAITIAN MIGRANTS TO ANOTHER
COUNTRY OR EVEN GUANTANAMO BAY.
>> Carley: THAT'S RIGHT.
THE NEW REPORT FROM NBC NEWS
CLAIMS THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ASKING DHS
ABOUT USING A THIRD COUNTRY TO
HOLD AND PROCESS HAITIAN
MIGRANTS ALONG WITH POTENTIALLY
DOUBLING CAPACITY AT THE MIGRANT
OPERATION CENTER IN GITMO.
WE REMEMBER THOSE IMAGES OF THE
HAITIAN MIGRANTS UNDER THE
BRIDGE IN DEL RIO, FLORIDA.
CONGRESSMAN GREG STEUBE IS A
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE FOREIGN
AFFAIRS AND HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND HE JOINS US NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, GOOD MORNING TO
YOU.
IT LOOKS LIKE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION MIGHT HAVE A PLAN
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE HAITIAN
MIGRANTS.
BUT DOESN'T INVOLVE SECURING THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
ADMINISTRATION JUST CAN'T FOLLOW
CURRENT LAW AND SECURE OUR
BORDER AND RETURN THESE
INDIVIDUALS TO THEIR HOST
COUNTRIES.
LET THEM FILE THEIR ASYLUM
CLAIMS IF THEY WANT TO FILE
ASYLUM CLAIMS.
LET THEM GO THROUGH THE
IMMIGRATION PROCESS THAT OUR
COUNTRY HAS SET UP WHERE OH,
BYES WAY, WE TAKE IN MORE
IMMIGRANTS THAN ANY OTHER NATION
IN THE WORLD, OVER A MILLION
EACH YEAR.
WHY DON'T WE JUST FOLLOW CURRENT
LAW INSTEAD OF TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT ALL THESE WAYS THAT WE CAN
ALLOW THE BORDER TO BE
COMPLETELY OPEN.
TO ALLOW FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
TO COME INTO OUR COUNTRY.
AND THEN WHEN THESE INDIVIDUALS'
ASYLUM CLAIMS ARE DENIED 96% OF
THEM.
THEN THIS ADMINISTRATION IS
REFUSING TO DEPORT THEM BACK TO
THEIR HOST COUNTRIES EVEN THOUGH
A COURT IS ORDERING THEM TO DO
IT.
>> Todd: IT LITERALLY MAKES NO
SENTENCE IT?
>> DOESN'T.
IT WILL.
>> Todd: IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY IN
NO SENSE.
THIS HALLOWEEN POLICIES ARE
HAUNTING THEM.
SEE HOW WE TIED IT ALL.
IN THE ECONOMY AND INFLATION
STILL TOP ISSUES IN THE FINAL
WEEK BEFORE ELECTION DAY.
' AND THE FED IS POISED TO MAKE
THE PAIN EVEN WORSE.
CONGRESSMAN, DOES ALL THIS --
ALL BUT GUARANTEE A RED TSUNAMI
NEXT TUESDAY?
>> YEAH.
DID I SEE THAT A TWIX BAR IS UP
53% ON THAT INFLATION FOR
HALLOWEEN TODAY.
SO, AVOID THAT ONE TREAT AS YOU
ARE GOING THROUGH YOUR
SUPERMARKET.
BUT THIS IS THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE
THAT IS FACING AMERICANS.
THIS IS WHAT IS GOING TO DRIVE
THE MIDTERM OUTCOMES.
IT'S NOT ABORTION.
IT IS THE ECONOMY, AND IT IS
INFLATION BECAUSE IT EFFECTS
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN EQUALLY
AND THEY ARE FEELING THE PAIN AT
THE GROCERY STORE.
THEY ARE FEELING THE PAIN AT
WALMART, HOME DEPOT, YOU NAME
IT.
WHEREVER THEY ARE GOING, THEY
ARE FEELING THE PAIN.
MODERATE TO LOW INCOME EARNERS
THEY ARE HAVING TO DECIDE
WHETHER TO PUT FOOD ON THE PLATE
OR MEDICINE OR GAS IN THEIR
VEHICLE TO BE ABLE TO GO TO
WORK.
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO DRIVE THE
MIDTERM AND HUGE SWEEP FOR
REPUBLICANS NEXT WEEK.
A WEEK AND A DAY FROM TODAY.
>> Carley: SO HE WOULD 8 DAYS
OUT NOW.
WHAT KIND SENSE ARE YOU GETTING
FROM THE SENATE WHAT MIGHT BE
HAPPENING THERE ON NOVEMBER 9TH.
>> RICK SCOTT SAID YESTERDAY HE
BELIEVES IT WILL TAKE 52 SEATS.
I THINK IS HE VERY VERY
CONSERVATIVE IN THIS ESTIMATE.
I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IF WE
GET 53 OR 54.
HOLD THE ONES WE HAVE TO HOLD IN
THE SENATE.
I TELL YOU I THINK THIS IS GOING
TO BE A MARKER FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
FAR LEFT POLICIES ON CRIME.
FAR LEFT POLICIES ON THE DOJ
INVESTIGATING PARENTS BECAUSE
THEY GO TO SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS
AND CARE ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION I THINK THE AMERICAN